allez on parle gastronomie à présent
avec un classique qui fait toujours
recette du mariage au vœux du maire le
pâté en croûte à tour il a même droit à
son concours le premier qui se déroulait
aujourd'hui à la ville arabelais elle
est à Turquie s'est penchée avec
gourmandise sur quelques créations de
nos charcutiers
quel sera le meilleur pâté en croûte
du Loire
lors de la région se dispute le titre
odeur allure et texture tout est passé
au crible par le jury il faut vraiment
se détacher du visuel avec le goût parce
que il y a de belles surprises en fait
là ce qu'il en ressort d'une dégustation
de 13 pâté en croûte c'est que je
remercie ceux qui ont qui ont pu varier
les textures le plus possible parce que
sinon c'est vrai que c'est tout much 12
jurés se sont attelés à la tâche parmi
eux des restaurateurs des universitaires
et professionnels du milieu de la
gastronomie alors comment juge-t-on un
bon pâté en croûte en fait on est sur
des critères assez précis sur la grille
de notation vraiment ça va ça se base
sur le visuel sur l'apparence de la
croûte le croustillant de la croûte pour
la dégustation
l'ensemble et l'homégalité des produits
à l'intérieur un concours organisé par
la ville arabe et à Tours et par l'Union
des métiers de l'industrie et de
l'hôtellerie dans un objectif commun
mettre à l'honneur le patrimoine
culinaire français au Moyen Âge bien sûr
mais même avant cela le pâté en croûte
était déjà à l'honneur et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est rester une sorte de de
chef-d'oeuvre à accomplir pour les bons
cuisiniers parce que c'est très
difficile de réussir un bon pâté en
croûte de la cuisine la gastronomie
c'est un élément important de notre
culture et de notre patrimoine le
verdict est tombé le château Belmont
gagne la médaille d'or en catégorie
traditionnelle quant à la recette
créative c'est la cité des formations de
Tours qui rafle la première place